[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo un retour sur
l'actualité de la semaine dans le
département
tout de suite les titres de ce vendredi
8 février saint quentin en yvelines
s'engage pour la cybersécurité le pack
lido un projet de recherche collaboratif
avec airbus cybersécurité le but
intégrer des fonctionnalités de sécurité
dans des objets sans compromettre leur
performance les jeunes générations
mouvement lancé par benoît hamon ont
commencé leur tour de france ils vont
notamment à la rencontre des services
publics
tristan péguilhan de le coordinateur du
mouvement yvelines sera notre invité
grand débat retour sur la grève
nationale ou encore interrogations
autour du financement du mariage de
carlos ghosn ex pdg de l'entreprise
renault
comme chaque vendredi coup d'oeil sur
l'actualité de la semaine permettre de
sécuriser l'internet des objets un
accord a été signé ce jeudi 7 février
entre saint quentin en yvelines et
airbus cybersécurité pour un projet
collaboratif intitulé pack lido qui
signifie protocole et algorithmes
cryptographiques léger pour l'internet
des objets
le but tester des solutions dans le
cadre de la cybersécurité avec plusieurs
acteurs universitaires et économiques
le reportage de nicolas d'andry
saint-quentin-en-yvelines territoire
d'expérimentation pour la cybersécurité
dans le cadre du pack lido un projet de
recherche collaboratif coordonné par
airbus sécurité avec des centres de
recherche et des entreprises
c'est un pacte entre une des plus
grosses entreprises françaises
qui a qui doit faire face à la montée de
ce marché après le numérique mais oui on
s'aperçoit que il faut protéger
numérique
donc c'est la cybersécurité est donc ce
marché dans train d'exploser
objectif du pack lido protéger les
données des objets connectés à travers
des systèmes d'algorithmes et de
protocoles cryptographiques
en clair éviter le piratage ou
l'espionnage numérique
l'expérimentation sur saint quentin en
yvelines s'appuiera sur le système de
m2m une start-up incubés elle développe
pour l'agglomération un système
intelligent destinés à l'éclairage
public
cette collaboration elle est à la fois
avec saint quentin sur un terrain
d'expérimentation pour notre solution de
gestion de l'éclairage public et
également avec pack lido parce que nous
sommes le support physique expérimentale
de leurs algorithmes l'algorithme qui
sont en train de créer et qui va
d'ailleurs comme ils l'ont expliqué au
delà de l'algorithme qui inclut
l'intelligence artificielle du machine
learning et donc ils vont implémenter
tout ceci sur notre système éprouvé
par la testabilité que ça fonctionne
la cyber sécurité un enjeu de plus en
plus important 74 % des pme françaises
ont déjà subi des cyber attaques
un phénomène qui engendre 400 milliards
d'euros de coût moyen par an dans le
monde et génération mouvement politique
lancé le 1er juillet 2010 est par benoît
hamon regroupe des dizaines de comines
et de comités jeunes partout en france
récente et glion bonjour bonjour
maintenant avoir le dos vous êtes le
coordinateur du mouvement aux jeunes
générations des yvelines quelle est
cette jeunesse qui se cache derrière ce
mouvement est bien les jeunes
générations ces organisations de
jeunesse du mouvement générations de
benoît hamon
c'est un pôle au sein du mouvement qui a
cessé qui est un cadre en fait pour des
les jeunes du mouvement supplémentaire
au mouvement générations c'est un cadre
kapoor qui a pour but de former les
jeunes qui n'ont pas forcément
l'habitude de faire de la politique qui
sont jeunes
ce sont des jeunes qui va nous on va
chercher sur le terrain qui n'ont pas
forcément l'habitude de la politique qui
s'engagent souvent pour la première fois
et donc le but c'est aussi pour
génération que nous ayons des
initiatives pour donner plus de
dynamique à notre mouvement
alors vous êtes étudiant en troisième
année de licence d'histoire à
l'université de 50 ans on y vit depuis
deux ans vous êtes militant au sein du
mouvement des jeunes générations
pourquoi ce choix et bien tout
simplement parce que au moment des
élections présidentielles de 2017
ben voila moi j'ai vu le candidat benoît
hamon qui portait des initiatives qui
était pour le moins particulière à
l'époque qui était très innovante
effectivement le revenu universel la
question de la transition écologique de
la baisse du temps de travail et de
transformation de la société vers une
autre en soirée une société du temps
libéré ce sont des sujets qui m'ont
beaucoup intéressé à l'époque et du coup
je me suis naturellement tourné vers
génération quand il a créé son mouvement
le président de la république a proposé
le grand débat national consacré à
quatre sujets la fiscalité
l'organisation de l'état la transition
écologique et la citoyenneté
ces deux derniers thèmes vous tiennent à
coeur au sein du mouvement des jeunes
générations
oui bien sûr mais toutefois on peut
noter que si c'est un président jeune
mâle la jeunesse appelle l'art de l'ue à
tenir plus à coeur que ça parce que
encore une fois il est lui de la
question de la jeunesse alors que le why
are président de l'union nationale
lycéenne a été blessée
très récemment manifestations par des
tirs de l bd alors la justice sociale un
des grands traits de caractère de votre
mouvement jeune génération
mardi la cgt a appelé à une grève
nationale de 24 heures suivie par
d'autres syndicats et des gilet jaune
à cette occasion le mouvement des jeunes
générations des yvelines porté par
benoît hamon en a profité pour mettre en
avant le service public
vous êtes allés à la rencontre des
cheminots en gare de versailles
chantiers ils ont d'ailleurs plusieurs
revendications
reportage tristan étudiant à
l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines milite depuis deux ans au sein
des jeunes de génération mouvement créé
par benoît hamon le 1er juillet 2017 ce
mardi 5 février le parti lance sa
journée de défense du service public
ce tour de france du service public
c'est de leur donner la parole leur
donner l'occasion de se mobiliser leur
donner l'occasion que tout le monde
puisse avoir connaître leur mot d'ordre
est que nous puissions bah voilà avec
eux travaillaient sur de nouvelles
alternatives à toutes ces questions à
voir quels sont leurs besoins
concrètement sur le terrain aujourd'hui
le service public a aujourd'hui c'est le
lier c'est le pacte républicain c'est le
pacte social c'est ce qui fait que nous
sommes égaux en droit et dans les fêtes
en cette journée de grève nationale
il participe à l'assemblée générale des
cheminots dans les locaux de la cgt en
garde versailles chantiers
le but avec génération c'est qu'on
vienne voir tous les acteurs du service
public
aujourd'hui c'est mon gros joint
mobilisation c'est l'occasion pour nous
aussi de participer à des actions
locales
la cgt est à l'initiative de cette grève
nationale de 24 heures un mouvement pour
réclamer une hausse des salaires une
meilleure justice fiscale
des militants et des gilets jaunes ont
d'ailleurs bloqué le marché
international de rungis dès minuit la
mobilisation s'est achevée à 5 heures ce
mardi matin
oui nous n'avons pas de doléances
vis-à-vis des gouvernements nous avons
des revendications apporter à nos
employeurs d'ailleurs c'est pour ça
qu'on est en grève aujourd'hui en
cessation du travail
on a de moins en moins de moyens pour
faire les choses qu'on transporte les
gens dans des wagons à bestiaux qui sont
mal entretenues qu' il n'y a pas des
moyens humains pour pouvoir assurer du
service je me rends compte que parfois
le chemin de fer fonctionnaient mieux au
19e siècle
parce qu'il y avait des gens nous
réclamons les hausses de salaires et des
pensions pour nos anciens aussi les
jeunes de génération continuent leur
tour de france dans les yvelines
ils se sont rendus dans l'après midi à
l'hôpital de plaisir comme on l'a
entendu en fin de sujet vous êtes allés
à la rencontre du personnel hospitalier
de l'hôpital de plaisir qu'a révélé cet
échange
et bien tout simplement l'hôtel de
plaisir on a montré du combat des
syndicalistes de la cgt de la force
ouvrière on a échangé du coup sur leurs
conditions de travail aujourd'hui bas
pendant deux heures effectivement l'état
du de l'hôpital public qu'il est
dramatique
on a rencontré des femmes qui ne se
battait plus pour avoir plus de salaire
pour des vols à des questions salariales
mais qu'ils se battaient désormais pour
avoir des conditions de travail décentes
pour pouvoir fournir un service qui ne
soit plus inhumain comme il l'est
aujourd'hui comme comme nous l'ont dit
dans leurs témoignages et les cheminots
les mêmes revendications
eh bien les cheminots et du coup le
personnel hospitalier ont dérobé de
revendications qui sont communes qui
sont bien là d'un côté une augmentation
des salaires mais aussi l'investissement
dans le service public pour offrir à
tous les usagers du service public un
service de qualité
parce que voilà on l'a dit le service
public c'est aujourd'hui yacht au coeur
du pacte social de la république c'est
le patrimoine de ceux qui n'en
et donc voilà l'objectif pour eux c'est
offrir à tous un service public de
qualité et donc c'est pour ça qu'ils se
mobilisent au quotidien et ses
rencontres locales font partie de votre
tour de france vous allez à la rencontre
des citoyens
quel est l'objectif de faire un constat
l'idée avec avec ce tour de france c'est
d'abord de faire un constat mais ensuite
d'en faire une analyse de faire une
analyse de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
en france on voit qu'il ya là un peu
partout voilà des suppressions de postes
d des investissements de la part de
l'état emmanuel macron l'a rappelé assez
récemment
son objectif c'est quand même de
supprimer 120 mille postes de
fonctionnaires en france d'ici la fin de
son quinquennat il ya déjà commencé en
2018 l'aï l'aar et très récemment
supprimé des postes dans l'enseignement
secondaire
pour nous c'est très inquiétant parce
que comme on l'a dit si demain il n'y a
plus de service public qui assurera
l'éducation le son ou encore le
transport bas du des plus précaires des
plus hauts
est ce que l'objectif aussi c'est pas de
faire connaître votre mouvement
au vue des européennes bien sûr il ya ce
côté là de à l'encontre des gens babolat
pour qu'ils nous connaissent mais c'est
vrai que quand on va rencontrer les
travers du service public c'est
généralement des gens qui ne connaissent
déjà parce que c'est forcément sur le
terrain on nous avons déjà soutenu sur
le terrain et ils nous connaissent ils
ont l'habitude de nous voir et ils
savent que ben on est de gauche et voilà
une écoute donc auprès des citoyens pour
construire vos projets aux élections
européennes justement quelles sont les
solutions que vous souhaitez apporter
pour la france et pour l'europe
et bien tout d'abord en france c'est
c'est avec cette politique de
désinvestissement de l'état
on l'a dit c'est très inquiétant c'est
pour la suite c'est très dangereux
la mobilisation des jeunes il ya une
étude qui a été faite elle est collé en
fait elle est corrélée d'une certaine
manière aux déserts médicaux qu'on voit
un peu partout en france et à dire
qu'une carte de la mobilisation des
jeunes de la densité de la mobilisation
des jeunes par rapport à la population
elle peut parfaitement et peut
parfaitement se s'aligner sur une carte
du
du manque justement de service public et
donc voilà c'est la preuve que le
service public c'est le lien social de
la république et donc voilà nounous vont
justement protéger les services publics
nous voulons réinvestir dedans donc on
veut investir à hauteur de 2 milliards
par an dans le service public de
l'enseignement supérieur nous voulons
engager plus d'un fermier plus de profs
pour donner aux cheminots le statut de
cheminot qu'ils ont perdu l'an dernier
et nous voulons pas pourquoi pas créer
de nouvelles missions de service public
comme bas un service public du transport
qui pourrait être gratuit pour tous
et au vue des européennes benoît hamon
votre chef du mouvement a déclaré la
liste je porterai aux européennes sera
la seule liste de gauche
si vous êtes la seule liste de gauche où
se situe le ps et la france insoumise
pour vous bien justement ce matin benoît
hamon a fêté sur rtl a justement déclaré
qu'il ouvrait la campagne des
européennes il dans le but de cette
campagne ils ouvraient une votation
citoyenne dans lequel il invitait tous
les partis qui se revendique de gauche
qui se revendique de la
social-démocratie de l'écologie
politique à participer à cette votation
le but c'est d'avoir un but préfet
d'avoir un vote préférentiel sur
plusieurs listes et il ya une sorte de
primaire 2.0 qui aurait pour but de
rapprocher ces partis en vue de cette
élection parce que nous voulons si nous
devons porter la seule liste de gauche
c'est parce que nous voulons avant tout
de l'union l'union donc une union - de
désunion moins de désunion exactement
permettre à tous les français de
débattre de questions essentielles c'est
l'objectif du grand débat national
dimanche il était organisé à trappes par
la députée nadia et avec la présence de
jamie de marie première adjointe au
maire de trappes et guy malandain le
maire de la ville
la ministre de la santé agnès buzyn a
fait le déplacement ce débat mené par
les citoyens a abordé plusieurs
thématiques
reportage c'est l'une des réponses du
gouvernement à la crise des gilet jaune
engagé le grand débat national
la mise en place d'une grande
concertation de terrain a commencé
trappes derrière cette initiative la
députée nadia est ce que j'attends fait
de ceux de cette journée c'est que la
parole soit vraiment ni la plus libre
possible que personne ne s'auto
censurent un débat sous forme de petites
tables rondes par thématiques avec à
chaque pôle un rapporteur général
pouvoir d'achat fiscalité les
discussions étaient bien nourris
si l'état mettez le doigt sur cette
fiscalité l'exil fiscal qui nous coûte
80 milliards par an une travailleuse je
pense que la france vit beaucoup mieux
les représentants des associations de
trappes ont également soumis leurs idées
on voudrait que l'état reprenne la
gestion des bailleurs c'est à dire en
profondeur c'est à dire de ce qu'ils
font de l'argent
les participants ne venait pas à tous de
trappes à l'image de cet habitant
militant pour une meilleure fiscalité et
avant de faire une réforme fiscale
commencé par produire des richesses que
l'exemple que j'ai pris vont distribuer
les pommes elle va produire les pommes
certains citoyens en ont profité pour
interpeller la ministre de la santé
agnès buzyn souvent on a un traitement
par les normes pour quatre jours dont
cinq jours et on nous donne une boîte il
va durer le traitement sont attendus
les traitements coup on est en train de
travailler sur la dispensation médicaux
enfin pilule par pilule les élus locaux
étaient également présents pour ce grand
débat il ya des décisions de fond à
prendre dans la solidarité l'égalité
un certain nombre d'éléments
administratifs qui sont superflus on
peut moderniser la france
elle en est capable et elle en a besoin
deux heures des échanges qui ont permis
aux élus députés et à la ministre de se
rendre compte de la situation sur le
terrain entre tout ce qui est fait au
niveau d'un gouvernement et la façon
dont ça se concrétise dans le quotidien
des gens et bien il ya un énorme écart
c'est peut-être la leçon qu'on va tirer
c'est que on doit se parler plus
fréquemment en direct tous les citoyens
attendent à présent la fin de ce grand
débat national pour voir sa finalité et
les décisions politiques qui seront
prises
tristan péguilhan je le rappelle vous
êtes le coordinateur des jeunes
générations des yvelines pensez vous que
les banlieues sont oubliés dans ce grand
débat eh bien on peut voir que les
banlieues à ne sont pas assez pris en
compte aujourd'hui effectivement c'est
dommage c'est au même titre que la
jeunesse est long de l ont très peu la
parole et on pense qu'au contraire
fédérer les impliquer un peu plus dans
ce grand débat notamment les yvelines
sont un département pneus surtout
banlieusards et d'autres nous pensons
que nous avons droit à la parole et
qu'il faudrait les impliquer un peu plus
justement lundi le président de la
république s'est rendu à evry
courcouronnes en essonne pour la
première fois il se déplace en banlieue
parisienne
les changes a été exclusivement dédié au
quartier un reportage de nos confrères
devient grand paris
[Musique]
pour son premier débat national en ile
de france
le président de la république a choisi
la ville d'evry courcouronnes
cette fois les changes a été
exclusivement dédié au quartier très
vite le ton est donné avec le maire de
grigny encore frustré de la récente
conclusion du gouvernement vis-à-vis du
rapport borloo qui faisait le diagnostic
des mesures à prendre dans les quartiers
sensibles bien sortir les abandonner les
questions se multiplient les constate
aussi comment faire pour renforcer le
tissu associatif
comment améliorer les conditions
d'éducation dans les quartiers sensibles
pour les invités
parmi eux élus représentants
d'associations parlementaire ou encore
habitants le constat est quasi unanime
le discours d' emmanuel macron est
intéressant mais ce sont désormais les
actes qui sont attendus faut passer à
l'acte aujourd'hui le diagnostic il est
partagé dans mon intervention mais ça a
été repris et tout le monde est d'accord
le président de la république il y à
rupture d'égalité républicaine
il faut refaire de l'égalité dans nos
quartiers il est capable d hier au plein
de choses maintenant il faut savoir ce
que ça va donner dans l'est dans les
actes c'est ça l'important
même constat du côté des associations
qui se plaignent d'une procédure
administrative trop complexe et pas
adaptée à la réalité du terrain
ce quartier la recette des cartes qui
sont toujours en marche donc au qui se
sont toujours un peu à l'écart des
problèmes qui concernent les français
c'était la première fois que les
quartiers faisait l'objet des changes
depuis le début du grand débat national
en 2015 l'insee recensé 26,7 pour cent
de personnes vivant avec moins de 1000
euros par mois dans la seule commune
d'evry
carlos ghosn aurait-il profité pour son
bénéfice personnel d'un contrat de
mécénat entre renault et versailles est
ce un abus de bien social le groupe
automobile s'interrogent sur le
financement du mariage de son ex pdg
célébrée le 8 octobre 2016 sur le site
yvelinois le château de versailles
aurait enregistré pour les festivités la
location du grand trianon comme
contrepartie d'un contrat de mécénat
signé avec renault en juin
ils 16 une prestation de 50000 euros
pour un événement privé et sans aucun
lien direct avec ce mécénat
le groupe au losange a annoncé qu il le
signaler à la justice de son côté le
château de versailles précise dans un
communiqué que renault comme le prévoit
la loi sur le mécénat a le droit à des
contreparties à hauteur de 25%
c'est à ce titre que le groupe a demandé
une mise à disposition du grand trianon
pour un dîner le 8 octobre 2016 si ni
carlos ghosn a ni son mariage ne sont
cités dans le communiqué carlos ghosn
est prêt à rembourser les 50000 euros
dont il a bénéficié pour l'organisation
de son mariage au château de versailles
le 8 octobre 2016 a précisé ce vendredi
son avocat jean yves le borgne carlos
ghosn est pour rappel incarcéré depuis
le mois de novembre au japon notamment
pour abus de confiance
comme chaque vendredi nous ouvrons nos
archives de tv soixante dix huit pour
notre séquence ça s'est passé et le 11
octobre 2000 2016 nous vous annoncions
l'arrivée de renault parmi les mécènes
du château de versailles un reportage
qui prend une toute autre tournure avec
ses interrogations autour de la location
du célèbre site pour le mariage de
carlos ghosn
[Musique]
c'est une première pour le groupe
automobile au losange son
président-directeur général on a lui
même fait l'annoncé hier le constructeur
français s'associe au château de
versailles et devient mécène catherine
pégard et olivier jose sont venus vers
nous pour nous parler cette restauration
du salon de la paix et on nous en avons
parlé avec notre président avec monsieur
ghosn qui a trouvé que c'était une
excellente idée parce que renault et le
château de versailles font partie de
l'inconscient collectif des français
on a voulu aller au-delà d'un simple
partenariat mais on a sollicité donc
renault pour un soutien plus important
est vrai mais c'est nord autour de ce
salon de la paix et je crois que carlos
ghosn a voulu cette association avec le
château de versailles puisqu'au fond
c'est parler de la création c'est parler
de l'art de vivre à la française c'est
parler des talents français derrière
cette oeuvre d'olaf sûrs eliasson tout
au bout de la guerre des glaces se cache
le salon de la paix une réalisation de
jules hardouin mansart et charles le
brun sa dernière restauration date des
années 1950 on va nettoyer les marmots
on va nettoyer les bronzes on va
nettoyer les stucs doré et puis on va
bien entendu restaurer les peintures la
restauration des peintures a fait
l'objet déjà de danalyse très poussé et
nous savons que sous les romains du 20e
siècle et du 19e
on a à peu près 80% de l'original de
lebrun et que cette originale de le brun
va donc nous allons essayer de le
remettre à jour c'est une restauration
conservation
il ne s'agit absolument pas de
reconstituer de recréer mais de
retrouver d'être au plus près de
l'original
le groupe automobile n'a pas souhaité
communiquer sur le montant de ce mécénat
le mécénat qui permet aussi de
bénéficier de réductions fiscales pour
les entreprises
les travaux débuteront au cours de
l'année 2017 et dureront 18 mois
[Musique]
avis aux lycéens de terminale vous allez
peut être profité de ce week-end pour
formuler vos voeux sur le site parcours
sup
il vous reste un peu plus d'un mois pour
le faire sur le secteur de saint quentin
en yvelines les choix de formation et
d'établissements pour les études
supérieures ne manquent pas tour
d'horizon avec aurélie rose
vingt mille étudiants répartis sur cinq
campus yvelinois lu vs qu propose plus
de 200 formations diplômantes du dut au
doctorat elle apparaît dans plusieurs
classements internationaux parmi les
plus prestigieux shanghai ou encore
celui du times higher education et saint
quentin en yvelines accueille également
sur son territoire de nombreux
établissements pour des formations plus
spécialisés la filière du transport est
représenté avec l'estac à l'école
montigny-le-bretonneux propose des
formations d'ingénieurs en cinq ans
après le bac
non mais
la rente et l'automobile a depuis la
rentrée 2010 8 son propre campus à
guyancourt 500 jeunes se forment dans le
commerce mais aussi la maintenance auto
moto et vélo pour celles et ceux qui
souhaitent opter pour les métiers de
bouche le lycée d'hôtellerie et de
tourisme est implantée à guyancourt à
plaisir l'école lenôtre permet également
de se former aux métiers de cuisine ou
de pâtissier son spectacle images le
premier campus audiovisuel européen se
trouve à saint quentin en yvelines plus
précisément à elancourt avec plus de
12000 mètres carrés d'infrastructures 3e
reçoit près de 900 étudiants chaque
année
enfin devenir développeur web community
manager ou analystes en cybersécurité en
quelques mois seulement
en 2018 l'agglomération a lancé son
label école du numérique
cet organisme a labellisé propose une
quinzaine de formations
objectif répondre aux besoins des
entreprises saint-quentinoise
après plusieurs mois de travaux la
ludothèque de montigny le bretonneux
reprend du service
un espace plus grand et nouvelle salle
dédiée aux enfants de 6 mois à 3 ans
nous avons découvert ses nouvelles
couleurs lors de son inauguration
mercredi 6 février
regardez
[Musique]
avec de nouveaux jeux et de nouveaux
espaces la ludothèque je tu ils de
montigny le bretonneux reprend du
service pour les enfants ce qu'on va se
colleter avec cette espace tel pour la
réaménager c'est un beau river la
relation parents enfants que les parents
jouent vraiment avec leurs enfants ils
n'ont pas une fois d'endroits où les
enfants se débrouillent comme ça c'est
vraiment la partie nouveauté de cette
année
oui j'aime beaucoup ce qu'il ya plein de
jeux à disposition du coup y'a plus de
jeu qu'à la maison
donc ça leur plaît en plus de cet espace
éveil pour les six mois à trois ans la
ludothèque bénéficie d'une grande salle
supplémentaire pour favoriser de
nouvelles animations comme les ateliers
d'initiation à la robotique
j'ai fait un circuit qui va suivre le
circuit mais il ya des codes de couleurs
il fallait rénover cette ludothèque
tout simplement parce que c'est un
équipement qui avait 30 ans 30 ans donc
au bout de 30 ans d'une part l'équipe en
avait beaucoup vieilli et puis de
l'autre dans les besoins
aussi évolué l'accès est libre du mardi
au samedi pour les adhérents ils peuvent
même emprunter des jeux pour un euro
[Musique]
merci tristan paix glion d'avoir été
avec nous bien savoir ado je le rappelle
vous êtes le coordinateur du mouvement
des jeunes générations en yvelines
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo passer
un excellent week-end retour de
l'information lundi dans le 7-8 journal
et dès 18 heures
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]